in a way the art of conversation is dead
like yes everyone has a podcast then yes
everyone's talking everyone else but
where can you congregate in front of
millions of people and have a real
conversation and yeah I'm gonna ask
people you know [ __ ] weird questions
but you see to me the mistake that
people can make is they can think that
the strippers and the vibrators and the
you know little people that that
represents pushing the envelope and what
they don't understand is
yeah it's sometimes it can and there was
probably a time when it did but at a
certain point sitting down and having a
real conversation with someone is edgier
then if you had 65 strippers come in
here right now right yeah you you you're
what you're having what you're doing and
it's I see this mistake all the time
people will start a new late-night talk
show and they want it to be edgy and
I've had some of them come to me for
advice and they've shown me I had
someone show me tape of their new show
and they just taped a pilot and it was
just them coming out
hard rock music they come out they spray
paint all over the wall they kick
something over they they're wearing half
a leather jacket there there's no form
they you interview someone the audience
then they throw cream pies then someone
interviews them then [ __ ] comes down
from the ceiling and I look at it and I
said it doesn't feel edgy it doesn't
feel revolutionary because you're not
the funniest thing in the world is give
someone restraint you need to create
restraint you need to create it's how
engines work you make a confined space
and then you create all this energy and
it's got nowhere to go and it pushes the
car forward stupid explanation of how an
engine works by the way but I don't know
anyway yeah okay well anyway you need
what you have here and where we're
sitting right now is a small space few
distractions and if you can get a person
there you can get them to really open up
that to me is edgier those kind of
conversations to me a way more
satisfying and and I that's why I like
this I mean that's why I said and maybe
what you were saying before was
addressing that that I you know I should
be proud of everything in my career but
but this is what I'm most proud of these
conversations what this book represents
to me
is a collection of my best stuff
conversations that unbelievably somehow
happened Rosie O'Donnell is sitting on
my couch I have access to Rosie
O'Donnell and I get into this heavy
conversation with her and I never felt
closer to her and I love sharing this
with the audience than having these
moments she's talking about the pain of
losing her mother when she's five and
taking a baseball bat and breaking the
her bones in her hand and and and just
wanted to feel anything but the pain of
losing her mother no one had ever
explained that to me before
that was mind blowing and I'm sharing it
with an audience and now I have it in a
book I have that and that's my time
capsule that's what I'm most proud of to
have a conversation like that with Rosie
O'Donnell are sitting on my couch and
that's what that's that's what I want my
legacy to be